Nate, Richard,
congratulations.
You guys have made it
into the final round
of this competition, which
means that you're both one
step closer to the title
of Forged in Fire champion
and a check for $10,000.
Now, we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is the kpinga.
Good luck.
We'll see you in five days.
I'm so excited to
be representing Texas.
That really is big for me.
I want to win this
for all of us.
I stole modeling
clay from my kids,
they're not going to be happy.
So this crazy kpinga,
nobody makes these.
I think that my metallurgy
background is going to give
me an advantage over Nate.
I think I want to end up getting
a lot of length on the handle,
bending this guy, bend this guy.
There's a kpinga in this
big old hunk of stuff.
Any time you take
steel and you bend it.
With every action,
there's a reaction.
It's compressing on one side,
elongating another, lot of
stress going into those joints.
Nate is an awesome smith and I
know he's bringing his A game,
as well.
Starting to take a
little bit more shape.
I have shaped the
kpinga complete.
I have to do a lot
of grinding today.
I'm trying to get in
here, and in here.
I can't get all the angles
that I want to because
of the shape of the weapon.
So I am taking
creative liberties
in how to grind this kpinga.
Whoa!
It's just a tricky
blade to grind.
Totally different from
the ordinary blades.
Gotta be careful.
Now, I have some very
fine art work to do.
Understanding exactly the
texture that I want here
is going to determine what
kind of chisel I need to use.
Just heat this up a little bit.
The technique I'm going
to be using for engraving
is based on Japanese metal work.
And they used pine tar to secure
their metal to a worktable.
I don't have any pine
resin, so I used hot glue.
This cannot be done well tense.
The patterns I've added to
this really give this piece
more of historical accuracy.
These are more than just
simple throwing knives.
The Zandes believed that these
are symbols of warriorship
and they were highly revered.
So I'm very proud that
the designs hand chiseled,
think it looks spectacular.
Perfect.
I'm really happy where
I'm at at this point.
So it's time to heat treat.
It may snap right here, there's
so many different areas.
This is a long blade.
I'm thinking, how am I
going to heat treat it?
I have to heat the whole
blade evenly, and then quench.
This is for $10,000.
This has got to be right.
[bleep], it doesn't fit.
If I can't get that blade
heated, it's not a blade.
If I stuck it in there
like that and took
the torch and heated that
guy at the same time,
pull it off, boom.
I can do that.
So I have the bigger
blade in the forge.
I'm heating up the part
that's sticking out.
This is not ideal heat treating.
This is not how I do things.
I don't know if this
has ever even been done.
If this works, it is
going to be a miracle.
Come on.
I've got no other options.
It's got to be done today.
Hard, hard.
All of it got hard.
I'm very happy.
I was wound up tight about this.
I am feeling a little
urgency because I have
three things to get done today.
Heat treat the blade, put on
a handle, and then sharpen it.
The heat treat goes swimmingly.
There's no warping.
So the handle, I'm going
to try out something
I've never done before.
I'm going to use a braid.
I chose goatskin because
it's excellent for braiding,
it's very strong and very thin.
Got to love leather.
The last thing I'm
adding to the handle
is a wax called saddle soap.
Goop it on, wipe off the excess.
This is just to
protect the leather,
and to give it a little bit
more of a comfortable grip.
It's just so much
energy in the air
that it actually
started to hail.
I think this is a good omen.
I'm bringing something
deadly into this world,
this is the birth
of something great.
Bladesmiths, the kpinga.
It's made to be a
throwing weapon.
With so much blade, I wonder
what kind of lethal damage
it's going to do.
Nate, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
Wow.
All right, Nate.
It feels good when you throw it.
The penetration of
your blade is so deep,
that will hit vital organs.
This is definitely the
back scratcher of death.
This weapon will kill.
Richard, you're next.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Awesome.
Wow.
Well Richard, when
you throw it it's
got good balance for
forward momentum.
Enough to penetrate
into the carcass.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen to test
the strength and durability
of your kpingas, I'll be
throwing them into our log
wall, three times each weapon.
Nate, you're up first.
So Nate, your handle is
really beautifully done.
But it's sticky.
Yeah.
That first throw,
instead of releasing here,
I released all
the way down here.
And it just was
stuck in my hand.
Having said that,
it buried itself
in that wood quite beautifully.
OK.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, Richard.
Let's do it.
I'm getting scared
at this point,
I'm hoping it's
just a timing issue,
of figuring out that throw, and
not an issue with the design.
That can be big problems.
Wow.
All right, so let's talk
about the design of your weapon.
The way your blades are
spread out seems a bit wide.
If this blade were here,
it would be traveling
forward as opposed to down.
But I think for me, the biggest
issue is the longer handle is
really increasing my rotation.
I do like the shape
of your handle.
It comes out of the
hand quite nicely.
And everything still
right and tight.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
To test the sharpness
of your blades,
I'll be throwing them into
our canvas sandbag wall here,
two times.
Nate, once again
you're up first.
You ready?
- I'm ready.
So Nate, it punctures the
bag like it's not there.
I like the positioning
of your blades.
But what's nice is
the short handle,
you're going to not have as much
to catch coming over the top
on rotation.
That's a big plus in
a throwing weapon.
Well done, it's a good thrower.
Thank you.
Richard, you ready?
Yes, sir.
Again, the positioning
of your blades
sets it up for a
different rotation
and I need to adjust
to throw this weapon.
But it's definitely
a sharp weapon.
It went right through the bag.
Good job.
Thank you.
Nate, Richard, through three
grueling rounds of competition
you've worked your
britches off to be standing
right here in this moment.
And for that we respect
you as craftsman.
However, in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one
Forged in Fire Champion.
Nate, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire Champion.
Richard, unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
Richard, you brought
us a deadly weapon,
that was strong and sharp.
But with that long handle and
the arrangement of your blades,
it was just harder to control.
I understand.
Richard please
surrender your weapon.
Richard, thank you.
The judges made
the right choice.
I would have made the
same choice myself.
I have absolutely zero regrets.
This was a fantastic experience,
the judges are fantastic.
Good job, buddy.
You know, David, he must be
a brother from another mother.
I've got a few fashion tips that
I'm going to share with them
later on before I leave.
I'm ready to get back to Texas.
Nate, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire Champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
[clapping]
How you feeling right now?
I'm feeling great, thank you.
Please present your
kpinga it to the judges.
I can't believe it.
Being a full time
bladesmith is my dream.
That future looks a little
more bright, and that feels--
wow.